an opera is a multivalent crazy art form
and you find that when you make one
thing a given everything else moves
around it so if it's this opera is going
to start this soprano suddenly the date
moves to a time that she's available the
repertoire becomes something that she's
comfortable with the room becomes a
theater that's appropriate to her etc
the cast becomes a cast that supports
her it's odd that one given makes
everything else move around it and the
same was true that the given was I was
going to come to this company and we
were going to produce operas and
everything else we had to figure out the
difficulty was that the turnaround plan
really didn't wasn't feasible it
contained wishful thinking on the
revenue side that meant that it wasn't
sustainable and so I needed to look very
carefully at what the realities were and
I had the sense in the first year like
how is it that my predecessors were able
to do 16 operas for 40 million dollars I
can't do five operas for 30 million
dollars the answer was that they didn't
do 16 hours for 40 million dollars they
ran very very large deficits every year
oddly though troubling that information
was it was a relief because it meant I
wasn't being held to a standard that was
unachievable rather that it costs more
money the flip side of that was that I
knew because I put on operas from the
ground up I know what everything costs
in an opera and so if I were walking
down the street and somebody had to be
30 million dollars and said hey can you
do five operas kid answers 5 habit 10
how about 15 of course I can do that but
here was a company that had a gigantic
cost structure of overhead and operators
an overhead business it's really a 19th
century kind of business but in this
case the overhead had eaten the company
alive there was nothing left to make art
with track there was insufficient money
just to stand perfectly still so the
task was to look at the overhead to
completely restructure it and to put as
much of the money on stage as we
possibly could and that is kind of was a
kind of thrilling problem to discover
and to work out a solution for if you
look around the country there are two
kinds of opera company there are the big
ones that have big contracts and there
are all the others the big ones of the
Metropolitan Opera Chicago lyric opera
San Francisco Opera and New York City
Opera if we look back when York City
Opera was
doing its most amount of work Mitch
patent opera was doing about 24
productions a season on a 300 million
dollar budget Chicago lyric opera was
doing let's say eight productores a
season roughly on a 60 million dollar
budget so much smaller San Francisco was
doing those eight productions around for
80 million dollars and New York City
Opera was doing 16 productions for 40
million dollars it was a huge amount of
work with very very little money in our
new size having cut out all this
overhead we're doing five productions on
a 13 million dollar budget so it's just
a much much smaller company so we have
to reshape the contracts we have to
match the new reality our old contracts
you buy time by the week and you pay
everybody whether they work or not so if
you want the orchestra you can't have a
flute you have all 60 or 70 members of
the orchestra you can't have them for 10
minutes you can't have them for an hour
you can tether for three hours you have
to buy them for a week that makes sense
if the amount of work you're doing is
higher than that guaranteed minimum but
it is crushing to the organization if
the amount of work you're doing is in
fact below that minimum you end up
spending money on people not working and
while it's extremely difficult for the
people who are used to getting the money
to suddenly not get the money there's
nowhere the company could continue
without that change for us it's very
important to be focused on what goes on
the stage and what is behind the stage
what's the administrative costs and add
new york city opera the overhead had
grown to be gigantic and what was left
over to put on the stage was tiny and
those overhead costs grow and grow and
grow they have their own people
motivating the cost to grow each cost
area has a vocal champion who wants that
cost ready to be bigger and bigger and
bigger but ultimately the success of
failure of the company is about putting
wonderful art on the stage and so one
needs to go through the budget area by
area to find out what really matters and
what doesn't matter and also to respond
to the exterior economy in ways that
make sense you know there are different
solutions for every different economic
situation
you